speaking of Airlines let's let's keep
talking in so bad stupid let's talk
about him um you know I don't so we had
like a favorite quote or anything from
the whole thing because I read a bunch
bro really remember any of them that
like what's funny to me is he talks on
the stand the same way he talks yeah in
real life yeah
like he think he Lori's lawyer will be
like hey clean it up a little bit you
know not as much like gang-related slang
and stuff like that but he's the he
stalks exactly the same way one of the
one of the best quotes so far is uh you
said pon de I don't know a pond it means
I don't know what that word means stupid
um did you watch the video of him
getting kidnapped I didn't know that was
that was some cold [ __ ] really I mean
not cold per se but it's a it's a weird
scenario I loaded up the video and then
I saw it was DJ academics I was like I
want to support him like quit out of it
yeah DJ academics yeah yeah no he so he
was in a car with a driver as a I think
I think it was at uber or like a car
service and the dude's name is a Jorge
Rivera or Jorge Rivera or whatever he
was driving Takashi and I don't want to
[ __ ] this up I might focus up but to my
understanding a car rear-ended him and
the driver of the car serviced
Jorge he looks at Takashi and he says
don't get out of the car he's like
encouraging him he's like it doesn't
[ __ ] matter you are who you are
we're not in a good area you're kind of
high-profile right now just don't worry
about it and then shadi
and the other dudes like run up on the
car and like they open the door and
they're like give me everything give me
everything get the [ __ ] out the car give
me everything and they're yelling at him
and and Takashi's like weirdly like he's
weirdly calm while pleading with them
and he's just like starting to dude
heart of he's like yo ha right now I
never did you want if did you wrong I
wanted to talk to you I I tried calling
you he's like then why you ain't call me
he's I tried but you got a new number
and like that it uh but
he's not like he's not like his voice
isn't like shaking shaking but he's like
definitely you know wait I understand I
don't understand who was kidnapping who
shadi his manager and some other dudes
were like basically yanking Takashi out
the car oh and this was like recent that
yeah you don't remember that old thing
when he got kidnapped like right before
his album dropped and he was like yo D
kidnapped me you don't remember that no
yeah damn
and then like then like hit not by your
own manager yeah and then like they I
don't forget I believe shadi was there
or maybe he wasn't just go watch the
video whatever and apparently like they
were filming him while they were
kidnapping him saying like I'm not Billy
and I think that was like something
related to like you know ninth ray
Bloods and like basically saying like
he's not down okay
and so like they like to say to the
driver like we just won't talk to him
just gonna take and they put him in a
car and the dude George like watches
them drive off and I think he tried to
tail him for a bit and while doing this
he's like he's on OnStar and he's like
calling OnStar like try to find a cop
and he's like doing circles and he finds
like a local cop and then he like tells
him what's going on and you know that's
kind of like where I tapped out on the
video but the whole situation is
interesting because the part that I
completely missed was that Jim Jones is
part of nitro like tre way yeah and like
I forgot that he was the one like on
that previous recording saying like oh
we should figure out how we gonna light
him and so like Takashi was on the stand
and they're like Jim Jones like you know
who is he's like oh he's like a like you
know with rapper like veteran rapper and
he's like is he part of the night right
blood he's like yes just snitching on
everybody buddy yeah and you did the
same thing with trippy red - yeah you
like try to bring trippy right into it
and he's just like it's funny like like
he's just saying way too much he was
saying something he said some [ __ ] that
wasn't even related to the case at all
yeah he snitched on himself for some
like other random [ __ ] yeah that like he
isn't even yeah it's so funny he's just
saying everything he's just saying as
much as he can it's been like I'll tell
I'll tell anything
I mean bro I'm it's it's I think you
know now everyone's posting these videos
and him like talking [ __ ] and you know
their videos like with him shoddy and
like other people and I don't know man
you just like it it's pretty surreal to
like see all these videos of him like
being like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
finna do [ __ ] to me and that none of
that and it's like him and like whoever
else is in the video it's like four of
them are going to [ __ ] jail yeah you
know and they were all like sort of
getting money together and like now like
you it's I was watching some video of
him like calling out to like you know
Chief Keef and little Reese and stuff
and uh a Cuban doll was like sitting
next to him okay and like right when
he's like so it's [ __ ] Chief Keef [ __ ]
yeah I saw that actually like oh yeah
she danced out the fragile yeah I'm not
with that well now I like I was watching
that video and I was like reading I'm
reading into the vibe a little bit okay
I was peeping the viol cuz you know the
vibes yeah you know okay you know the
vibes here no but honestly I was looking
at everyone in the background and their
facial expressions now I read them as
like like they're just letting him go
mm-hmm but it's like none of them are
really in agreement with what he's
saying yeah like they all kind of it's
it now to me it reads like they all know
that he's a clown and they're just
letting him talk that way for the sake
of money yeah and but I feel like
previously yeah it's like everyone yeah
but round like you know the Paul
Brothers and now yeah yeah yeah but I
feel like it's one of those things where
like early on if if nobody like if
you're caught up in the hype and like
you're just so focused on him like you
would have never you wouldn't think
twice about that video or like you
wouldn't read into the emotions of the
other people in the scene like you just
don't care okay
I don't know I just I feel like now all
this [ __ ] is being unearthed and then
it's kind of been like maybe under our
nose the whole time kind of thing so I
think that's what makes those videos
surreal to me mmm like you go back and
watch it and you're like oh [ __ ] they
never actually like them yeah but it's
like they were just using him yeah but
in the moment you don't read into that
yeah you don't even see that but it's
funny that it would works for him right
mm-hmm that's his whole thing is he was
they were just using him but yeah so
like case isn't it yeah I don't know I
mean it's gonna be
yeah it'll be interesting to see how it
pans out yeah we'll see how it pans out
yeah they're just wanted to say pans out
I've got it yeah I [ __ ] see how it
pans out though yeah we will definitely
see opens oh no I think it's the whole
thing is wild he's gonna get out of jail
for sure maybe he's gonna get out and
he's gonna just mine what no my main
takeaway was everyone now the general
public saw that kidnapping video that's
the best thing that could happen to him
really he's now the general public is
saying like oh man
y'all don't know what you would have
done in that situation of course you
would yeah y'all saying don't snitch
look at the way they're treating him
they're kidnapping him they're robbing
him dude he's gonna get the middle 30%
sympathy he's gonna be able to drop a
record no problem oh yeah for sure he
will come right the [ __ ] back yeah and
he won't be he won't be rapping about
Trey Way and all that yeah he'll go move
to plus he's got the whole like
reggaeton angle like they don't give a
[ __ ] about gang like affiliations in the
States do they I mean I don't know I'm
not gonna speak on whether or not I
don't think you know like that's a whole
genre of music that I don't know how
maybe I don't know [ __ ] about that but
like I don't know I just feel like
that's about like just partying having a
good time
but maybe not I mean you know there's
like you think he's like still talking
about like Trey Trey away when he's like
doing Spanish [ __ ] I mean no but he
could talk about whatever I think more
than anything
Takashi has like his sound I think he'll
just be able to talk about like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and getting money and yeah the
rap community will be like I you're a
snitch you're like you're a rat like
this and that but the general public
like don't care about that [ __ ] no I
think though the average 30 percent
person will just be like Oh Miz whatever
yeah little kids will go to jail what
yeah little kids will ride for them they
like you but yeah we like Takashi and
you know what and they're gonna say you
know [ __ ] whoever yeah I'm a snitch -
yeah just like backfires cool I want a
snitch
everyone's snitching on each other for
just just [ __ ] they maybe even didn't do
yeah it's gone with the cops yeah snitch
on telling everybody my friend stole
something from 7-eleven just now
he took a 30 break yeah he's a little
easily you should keep an eye out for
[Music]